Salut, c'est la dernière vidéo sur la mémoire, de l'année.
Est-ce que vous voyez ce que c'est ça dans le fond ?
Alors oui, c'est une chaise
Mais pas n'importe quelle chaise,
Puisque c'est une "chair director"
Du Youtube
LE Youtube
Il est beau le youtube
Il y a eu une remise de prix au Youtube Space et j'ai gagné quelque chose et du coup ils m'ont envoyé ça.
Et c'est le genre de connerie que j'aime bien.
Alors je filme comme ça, parce que j'ai encore oublié mon pied de caméra
Pour changer
Et en parlant d'oubli, aujourd'hui on va parler du fait d'oublier d'arrêter d'oublier
Parce qu’il faut arrêter ... d'oublier.
GÉNÉRIQUE !
(Musique du générique)
Cette année je vous ai fait aussi des vidéos sur la mémoire qu'on peut
retrouver dans la playlist "trucs de
mémoire" et je pense que la dernière
peut parler aisément du fait
qu'il faut pas oublier ce qu'on a appris. C'est bien d'avoir des méthodes,
pouvoir les consolider c'est mieux.
Il faut savoir quand même que notre mémoire
à court terme elle fonctionne aux environs de 18 secondes c'est donc très rapide
Avec toutes les méthodes et les techniques qu'on a vu cette année on retient plus
longtemps et plus efficacement parce
qu'on crée des connexions entre plein
de choses. On n'a pas juste un lien
qui mène à une information mais des
dizaines de liens dans tous les sens, c'est imagé, c'est avec des souvenirs, c'est plus efficace.
Ca ne veut pas dire qu'il faut pas réviser
sauf que j'aime pas trop bien le mot réviser
On va dire qu'il faut réactiver
régulièrement l'information pour ça
Il y a plusieurs techniques. Lesquelles?
Bah je vais vous le dire, je vais vous dire lesquelles
Mais avant de bien vous dire lesquelles, voyons quand même : bien apprendre
Quand vous voulez apprendre efficacement, peu
importe la méthode que vous utilisez
vous avez besoin d'un temps de
concentration
Ce temps de concentration en fait il
fait un pic, on va dire qu'il y a
un démarrage, qu'après il y a une espèce d'âge d'or durant un certain minutage
Et après ça descend sec. La réelle capacité
d'apprentissage est entre 20 et 45 minutes
pour un être humain normalement constitué
Le seul moyen de bien apprendre est d'être dans ce temps de concentration
jusque-là on est tous d'accord. Et bien
sachez qu'une fois qu'on a fini notre âge d'or
de concentration, que tout est redescendu, qu'on n'arrive plus à apprendre
on a complètement perdu notre élan et
on pourra pas le reprendre. Mais c'est
la seule méthode qu'on connaît puisque
c'est celle qui est organisée en cours
par exemple quand on vous fait un cours d'une heure, deux heures ...
La bonne méthode d'apprentissage c'est
de faire une pause en plein âge d'or
Et de reprendre après, puisqu'on est déjà
échauffé, on va reprendre et
refaire une pause etc ..
Le bon timing, qui est celui que je
recommande depuis des années et c'est
celui que je pratique pour moi, c'est 20
minutes d'apprentissage
5 minutes de pause. En fait c'est
super efficace et c'est beaucoup
Vous allez faire 20 minutes d'apprentissage, 5 de pause, 20 d'apprentissage, 5 de pause
20 d'apprentissage, 5 de pause
autant de fois que vous le souhaitez
Sauf que les 20 minutes d'apprentissage
c'est sans l'ordinateur, téléphone coupé,
sans aucune distraction et les 5 minutes
de pause elles sont top chrono, c'est 5 vraies
minutes de pause vous pouvez aller manger
un morceau, vous lever, vous dégourdir les jambes, écouter de la
musique, passer un coup de téléphone
mais 5 minutes seulement et vous
reprenez
pareil en recoupant toute distraction. Si
vous arrivez à faire ça, en 1h15
vous aurez eu 1h d'apprentissage et de concentration réelle
et 15 minutes de pause. Alors que si
vous aviez fait 1 heure d'affilée au
bout de 45 minutes vous auriez tout
perdu, les 15 minutes d'après elles auraient
été complètement inefficaces et encore
je vous dis 45 minutes, pour les meilleurs d'entre nous
Y en a au bout de 20 ou 25 ou 30 minutes
c'est déjà fini
et vous auriez pas pu reprendre, alors
que là vous auriez pu continuer ce cycle
sur deux heures et demie
pour apprendre 2h efficacement.Et une bonne méthode d'apprentissage est de faire
de l'apprentissage croisé.
C'est-à-dire de ne pas se concentrer
durant des jours et des heures et des
heures que sur un sujet spécifique là
aussi y a une croyance populaire  qui dit : on doit être focus sur un seul objectif non
Plus vous allez multiplier les choses
plus vous allez ressusciter de l'intérêt de la concentration et vous allez être efficace
Donc vous pouvez faire 20 minutes de quelque chose
20 minutes d'autre chose, 20 minutes d'autre chose
et tourner comme ça en boucle sur 2h et demie, ou sur 3h45 etc...
Vous pouvez faire des cycles autant que vous voulez. Une fois qu'on a appris,
il faut donc réviser, je vous l'ai dit j'aime pas le mot "réviser", parce que déjà
je trouve qu'il renvoie à des mauvaises
énergies, à des mauvais souvenirs
En fait il faut juste relire, vous pouvez relire régulièrement tout ce
que vous avez fait. Si vous avez fait des mind map, relisez les mind map ça va
réactiver l'info
Si ce sont des choses plus traditionnelles, relisez les
simplement
Ne cherchez pas à réapprendre, relisez, et la technique ultime
pour relire et pour se rappeler c'est les
flash cards. Je vous ai fait une vidéo sur
les flash cards que je vais vous remettre
sûrement ici enfin au dessus de moi et dans
la description. Étudiez ça, mettez ça
en place, ça prend pas trop longtemps,
vous pouvez aussi utiliser un bullet journal
pour ceux qui s'en servent
Peut être que vous ne connaissez pas le bullet journal, si c'est le cas renseignez vous
un petit peu, si vous voulez une vidéo là-dessus parlez en dans les commentaires c'est un outil
hyper efficace, pour s'organiser pour la
créativité
pour se donner des objectifs
comme ça d'apprentissage long terme et
de réactivation c'est bien
Je m'égare, revenons en aux flash cards, essayez de mettre ça en place, parce qu'en même temps
ça organise un peu votre timing, si vous utilisez la vraie méthode
du classement des flash cards
Voilà c'était les petits conseils de
fin d'année, de Fabien sur la mémoire. J'espère
que ça vous a plus, si c'est le cas n'oubliez pas de liker la vidéo et de
vous abonner. Rendez-vous demain à
11 heures demain.
Ciao.